une grande partie du travail consiste à rechercher les
pires deux personnes
s'avèrent j'excelle dans ce domaine
j'essaie juste de gagner ma vie vous savez que le
boost coûte de l'argent généralement Jessica Jones
je t'ai vu que veux-
tu savoir  le mur
arrête de bouger appelle une voiture lente je
vois que c'est un héros mets juste une cible sur
ton dos
j'y suis allé fait que cette poupée et
s'il y avait quelqu'un d'autre là-bas mais
sa capacité était de faire faire aux gens tout
ce qu'il  voulait qu'il aimait mon contrôle
tu n'as aucune idée de ce que j'ai fait ce qu'il
m'a fait faire Jess n'est pas là maintenant il est toujours
toujours là elle oui tu
aimerais m'inviter à Lodge absolument killgrave
laisse une traînée de gens brisés derrière
lui tu m'as fait sauter pendant des heures aussi haut
que je pouvais il a dit que je n'étais jamais aussi bon
que toi
il est de retour il vient pour moi commençons
maintenant Jessica je suis le seul qui
te correspond et nous sommes inévitables Oh mon Dieu non
fais ça le diable a fait
je vais bien
listo Oh Jessica je suis ce poêle je joue
l'héroïne moi je suis  l'étoile Zoey
vous